want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
amazing motivation from the one and only
marie forleo
enjoy
in the beginning when i was first
growing the business and first getting
it off the ground i was definitely
work-life balance was less of a reality
because i just had to work constantly in
order to keep the lights on
but now at a different stage for me it's
really about shutting things off and
it's about recognizing that even though
the world says that you should be on
social media all the time that you
should be on all of these different
channels that more is better that's
actually not the truth bigger isn't
better and more isn't better when it
comes to work-life balance the more that
you shut down and kind of check out and
give yourself time and space you come
back and you realize you actually didn't
miss anything all you missed was a lot
of noise and i think as business owners
it's vital that we stay connected to our
own voice and our own intuition and if
you're constantly connected to the
outside world you can't hear your own
intuition you're so overwhelmed with the
voices of the world that you lose your
own inner compass and for me it's vital
so i actually shut off a lot
we honestly don't think about our own
mortality enough i think death is one of
those taboo kind of topics in our
culture and we don't really face it we
don't think about it we don't talk about
it enough we don't imagine ourselves
dying enough we don't really just dive
in and one of the weird little tricks
that i use on myself especially when i'm
just being horrible in my own
relationship or i'm being not the person
i know i'm capable of being i'm having a
temper tantrum i'm stressed i'm just
being an ass whatever it is i've used
this in my relationship with josh where
i will literally fast forward to the
point where like i imagined him
laying in a coffin and me going why were
you such an [ __ ] why didn't you take
that time why did you let that fight go
on for four hours or a day or whatever
it is or in those moments where i feel
myself tightening up or shutting down or
withholding love i try and check myself
before i wreck myself i go there's gonna
come a day where you're gonna flash back
on this moment and wished that you just
gave him a hug
or wish that you went in
and said i love you
it's coming
for all of us
so if you can remember that
now
you change everything when i was
bartending i was fully bartending like i
wasn't talking to myself about oh my god
i should be dancing right now or i
should be working on my coaching
practice i was just really into
bartending and when i was dancing i was
like you know being the best hip-hop
teacher dancer i could possibly be when
i was being a coach same kind of thing
and i think that practice of being fully
engaged
in the thing that you're doing conserves
a ton of energy and that's what most
people don't do part of what was also
challenging for me when i was starting
off as a coach was
recognizing the truth that i didn't just
want to be a coach i loved writing
i loved hip-hop i loved dance i loved
fitness there were all these different
things that i was passionate about and
while i was growing my personal coaching
practice i kept feeling conflicted
because i didn't want to just be one
thing has anyone ever felt that way
so uh i would listen to the voices in my
head which were like and basically the
voices in my head were so trained by
traditional wisdom and traditional
thoughts about you have to pick a niche
you have to narrow down you have to
choose one thing and be good for it be
um be really good at it and that's how
you'll be known and
when i realized that that voice wasn't
the voice i should listen to that there
was this truth that i was this
multi-passionate person and that living
in the present moment which eckhart
teaches was all about um really
listening to your own inner guidance
and being in the here and now and not
stressing so much up here that really
opened the door for me to say you know
what screw it i'm going to go take dance
classes i'm going to go learn about this
i'm going to do all these different
things and it that training to be in the
moment and to listen to my own inner
guidance allowed me to disconnect from
all the bs voices in my head that were
torturing me
torturing me a book that really changed
my life was half the sky by nicholas
kristoff and cheryl wudun and it really
opened my eyes to the injustice and
prejudice that women face
all around the world not only in this
country but in the developing world and
women are our most under utilized
resource and i feel like it's up to us
to take care of each other it's up to us
to look and see what the needs are and
to reach out and to fill those holes
it's like we can't wait for anyone else
we are the answer so for me it's vital
to use everything in my power whether
that's financial resources whether
that's the platform that we've built
whether that's my connections anything
that i have at my disposal what are the
things you think you're not doing well
in your business
i think a lot of these have started to
shift with this book project so i tend
to be a person um there's this comes
from two places
i like to be involved in things because
i'm very collaborative yeah so i love to
see how things are turning out and i
love to like put my spin on them or at
least have my input um but at the same
time um you know that can be overbearing
i don't want folks to feel like they
constantly have to run things past me
you know my team definitely knows i
trust them um
so
the thing that i haven't done well in
the past is delegating enough
letting go enough control
and particularly with this project it's
pushed us all so far outside of our
collective comfort zones that it's been
a joy to be like you guys make the
decision you're amazing you're
intelligent you're smart whatever you
choose i'mma be happy with wow yeah
that's been good hard to do to let go of
that right it's been great it's been
good it's been really great like the
fact that i'm this like awake and happy
and and like in it right now speaks to
my
you know kind of let go and let jesus
take the wheel and in this case jesus
manifests as my team it's amazing just
let people make decisions and move on
yes you do what you need to do and let
everyone else do what they need to do
yeah it's the only way to sanity you
know so many of us we want to do our
best so we have high standards and all
of those things are wonderful but there
is a distinction between having high
standards and performing at your best
and suffering from perfectionism which
in the extreme can actually be deadly so
there's some research out there
and this is sad but it's it's important
to know when they started talking to
folks um who had a relative who recently
took their own life they discovered that
in over 50 percent of the cases without
prompting the relatives described that
person who's no longer here as being a
perfectionist
they could never meet their own
standards they never felt like they were
good enough and when that roots in on a
deep level
you can understand how someone could
feel that depressed and feel that lost
and feel like nothing they ever do could
ever match up so it's a real thing and
for me you know i have strains of that
and i'm so happy you know age and
experience you kind of see the world in
a different light but the thing that's
helped me the most and what we focus on
in the book is this idea of focusing on
progress not perfection when that's your
metric for success did i learn something
today did i make an inch of progress
even if it doesn't look like progress so
there's actually a
a great graph in the book i'll see if i
can describe it
so
people imagine that progress kind of
looks like this you start out here and
you're just new at something and then
you inch up an inch up an inch up an
inch up an inch up an inch up and it's
almost like this straight line to get to
your goal when in reality progress kind
of looks like this you start here as a
neophyte and then you maybe inch up and
then you take five steps back and then
you go way down and then you swirl
around and you go up and down and it's
just this incredibly squiggly line where
there are setbacks
you absolutely feel like maybe you've
taken 10 steps back but that's still
progress so true so when we're focusing
on progress not perfection it's a really
great way to keep your action in
perspective and to keep moving forward
because perfectionism really just keeps
people spinning their wheels be boldly
not for everyone so what does that mean
so sales prevention is this beautiful
thing in business and sales prevention
is when you proactively tell people do
not buy my product do not buy my program
you might be asking yourself why here's
why
because not every product is right for
everyone and that's true no matter how
great you think you or your product or
your service is because you cannot and
will not please every person so you
really want to take that fact and use it
to your advantage you want to focus on
attracting your ideal customers and
really repelling the rest so for
instance in b school here's what i tell
people
if you want to learn how to raise money
from venture capitalists we're not for
you wonder why because we don't cover
that
if you're looking for an easy button to
press and then bam money starts shooting
out of your laptop we're not for you you
know why because that's not how a real
business works people
and if you think that you already know
everything there is to know about list
building and online marketing and how to
sell with integrity we're not for you
because you know why if you already got
all the customers and all the integrity
you'll ever need keep your dollars
because i have too much integrity to
take them from you
bottom line is this when you are boldly
not for everyone you're gonna attract
way more of the people that you are
right for and that my friend is the
formula for creating raving fans that's
the secret to making your business a
real joy to run and when that happens
you know what starts shooting out of
your laptop
no
not money
integrity rainbows we're living in a
time when we are allowing our brains to
be trained to underperform
we've become addicted to checking our
phones right to social media and all
kinds of stuff and in doing so we are
reducing our ability to stay focused and
do the deep important work that we're
meant to do in this world now what i'm
about to suggest isn't complicated and
it is not time consuming but it will
require you to take back control of your
time
take back control of this beautiful
brain and trust that your world will not
immediately fall apart if you don't
immediately respond to every ding or
every buzz or every question or every
request put your entire life on airplane
mode so don't try and ignore your phone
or ignore the emails or ignore the slack
messages or whatever else that you have
that dings and rings and pops up that's
like me telling kuma to ignore this
slice of salami ain't gonna happen
who can't ignore the salami
who can't ignore the salami
so rather than resist temptation just
eliminate it and that means you have to
put your entire life on airplane mode
now obviously turn off all the
notifications so close all the tabs
close all the windows turn off the apps
and especially for your phone i suggest
just turning the damn thing off
however you also gotta shut off some
people too and that means that you might
have to tell your kids
and your spouse and your co-workers that
for the next two hours or one hour or
three hours that you don't exist kind of
like this
see
nobody here
one of the new things that we're doing
which i'm so thrilled about you know um
having a digital company often feels
like you're on 24 7. you know social
media is a very 24 7 kind of animal and
our business technically you know you
can have customers all the time so one
of the things that we're changing is in
december we're shutting the entire
company down for two weeks no
newsletters nobody's on email nobody's
on anything and so for me it's vital
that when you love your work so much and
in this new digital space it's easy to
become a workaholic it's easy to always
be on and it's easy to start letting
other parts of your life start to take
the back burner and i want to take a
stand for every woman that works with me
that she creates space she creates space
to get re-inspired she has huge chunks
of time for her family for other things
she's interested in um to go out into
the world and to make change in
different ways that perhaps aren't even
related to our company what will you
regret if it's 20 30 we're doing this
again sitting here and you're like i'm
really upset on myself because i didn't
do this in my personal life and my
business my health my family the world
yes i would say the only thing i could
foresee at this moment not regretting is
not continuing
to take that quality time with people i
love that would be the thing that if for
whatever reason
i started making justifications right
well this opportunity is so amazing so
i'm going to go here and do this
that would be the only thing to be
super transparent with you yeah because
looking back
on these past ten years the quality time
with people that i love
is
everything
and
i know this so viscerally in my body is
that we're not going to be here forever
and we never know when the people that
we love
wrong gone
and
so for me there is nothing more
important
than maintaining and
enriching and deepening those personal
like friend relationships josh my family
like making sure that i show up
as fully as possible and not letting
anything take me off track from that
because it's
you know
having not had money and you know
starting with like tons of debt and
building everything from the ground up
and now being in a different position
it's like i can see so clearly the
success on an exterior level like that's
amazing and i'm grateful for it but
nothing can make up for
not having a sense of love in your life
and not having people that you care
about and that you're invested in so
there's nothing that i could strive for
or reach for that's going to be more
important than this so when i was first
starting b-school i was really excited
about getting it out into the world and
i went to a marketing conference to
network and to meet people and to find
promotional partners and so i was really
excited to tell people about the program
and i was on this escalator heading up
to like the first session of the day i
was really excited and there's this guy
in front of me and you know at
conferences everybody likes to introduce
themselves and learn about what you do
and so this guy looks at me and he
looked at my name tag and goes oh you
know what do you do what are you doing
here sorry i started telling him about
b-school this online business school for
women entrepreneurs
and his face kind of went blank and he
looked at me and he's like oh
that's cute
do you expect to make money with that do
you have a rich husband who's
bankrolling you
and i was so
stunned that this guy said this right to
my face meanwhile the truth was that i
was supporting myself my own business
for almost a decade at that point i had
already been making quite good money and
no i did not have a rich husband
it took everything in me not to want to
really deck this guy and throw him off
the escalator but it was probably one of
the moments that fired me up so much
because this guy saying something so
rude and so chauvinistic to me all it
did was get me more fired up to prove
him and anyone out there who
underestimate underestimated me
completely wrong well i was believing
that if i didn't work constantly
that i wasn't a worthy person
that i wasn't
doing enough to make my business
successful that i was perhaps letting
people down
and so i had to really shift that and
understand that you know i come from a
background i don't come from a wealthy
background so the work ethic in my
nuclear family is very strong like my my
dad owned a small business my mom
although she stayed home with us she was
constantly doing stuff constantly
working constantly fixing things
constantly doing things that took care
of the family so that's the kind of dna
i grew up with was like no if something
needs to get done you get it done it's
not like you sit around all day and
eating bon bons and watching tv yeah
yeah so um yeah so so that's kind of how
i got there but then i really i had to
readjust if i actually wanted to not
only have a successful business but have
a successful life and that
yeah that like just
devastating sense of loss
it's pretty crazy how fast that'll snap
you at us oh it will snap you out of
some and it will stop you from being in
a temper tantrum and you can use that
same notion again some people might say
this is incredibly morbid i say it's
incredibly inspiring i say if you can
use it to wake yourself up out of that
slumber of staying in your temper
tantrum or being pissed at your parents
or pissed at your friends or pissed at
someone who again if you can see them as
an innocent doing the best that they
possibly could with whatever tools and
understanding and beliefs and thoughts
they had in that moment you can find a
way to transcend to reconnect to your
heart and to be that love that you
really are my first gig out of college
was on wall street on the new york stock
exchange and
this is pre everything this is like just
out of college 21 years old and i knew
one of my drives i wanted to be really
successful but not just to like get
shoes i knew i wanted to
make money because i wanted to make a
difference i wanted to be able to take
care of my family i wanted to be able to
contribute to causes that i believe in
and so i knew in order to do that in my
own mind i was like well i want to make
a lot of money and make this stuff
happen but when i was on wall street
even though so many people that i worked
with
uh multi multi-millionaires i mean the
money was ridiculous while they were
financially rich they were spiritually
bankrupt
and i
felt like there was a part of me that
was dying inside and i said this is not
my path i don't know what my path is but
i need to leave this because i feel sick
and so i think many people feel like
that you can find yourself in job and
job and job and you want to do a really
you want to do great work in the world
you're giving it your best that some
little voice inside is saying this isn't
me
this isn't me and i kept having that
voice until finally i left the corporate
world and started my own business i
always had a dream to have an amazing
company that didn't necessarily have one
home base
i'm fascinated by technology and for me
it's about finding the right people who
also believe in that same idea that you
can do great work that you don't
necessarily have to share the same
physical space all the time but that if
you're united behind a vision and behind
values and behind
wanting to do incredible work in this
world that you can create
amazing results and only see each other
a couple times a year so for us
it's really about making sure that
whoever comes onto the team shares the
same beliefs that we do shares the same
vision cares about making a difference
and also is really self-motivated you
know just because i'm the ceo of my
company everyone else in the company is
very entrepreneurial they might not want
to run a company themselves but they're
self-starters they're completely
motivated they're always looking for
ways to solve problems they have an
attention on the bottom line and they
want to create huge change in this world
and then in the company
um
i don't know if i've ever told you this
story but uh one day i was in new york
and i was having like a really bad pms
craving for carbs i was just like i was
like
mama needs some carbs and i was feeling
like a croissant and there was this
great little french bakery around the
corner that i'd never been to and i'm
like i'm gonna go get my croissant right
now so i roll up to this little french
bakery and on the window there was like
this handmade sign that said you know
offer vacation
back you know july 18th and it was like
this two-week thing wow you're like what
and i was like wait wait what their
business you need to be here yes and yet
there it was empty and this simple
little like hand-drawn sign and in that
moment louis i had this notion i was
like wait a minute i'm running this
digital company i have all of these
amazing beautiful gorgeous souls that i
work with and we're producing content
once a week
every week non-stop
when do we ever take a break and the
advantage for me like josh who works in
entertainment like series sometimes
they'll have you know you watch your
favorite series like i love hands maids
tale i love stranger things you see 11
or 12 episodes and wait a year and yes
right
and i thought to myself why do i not
have down time built into my business
and this was about the time when also
there was just a cultural uprising with
like you know hustle 24 7 and you have
to work non-stop and like never take a
break and i'll i'll sleep when i'm dead
and i'm like those are horrible messages
for your health yeah so we decided after
i saw so after i had my croissant
craving i told my director of operations
i said starting right now we're gonna
close the company down for two weeks in
the summer
and two weeks in the winter and
in addition to people's already having
their yes their vacation time and we
started that i guess maybe i don't know
five six years ago it might be wrong on
those dates but a good number of time
ago and so our company goes dark twice a
year
and now the company's at a place where
not everyone in customer service takes
off those exact same two weeks so they
stagger so that we can take care of
people but everyone has two weeks of
dark time two weeks of dark time
and what's great about that is that you
don't get
fomo
thinking that you're off and there's all
these other things happening and there's
projects moving ahead and there's these
things that you want to be in on but
you're like feeling that tension because
the rest of the company is moving ahead
and you're trying to relax so it's been
a game changer for us if you had to give
someone who's recently graduating from
our program a piece of advice what would
you say i would say to
learn and to execute on your unique
vision define success for yourself
figure out what that means to you don't
get
taken over by the world's definition of
success or your families or what your
friends are doing or what anyone says
that equals success once you can get
clear on that vision then you need to
create a plan to make that come to life
and to prioritize i think one of the
biggest tragedies of our time is i hear
so many people from every walk of life
health coaches all over feeling so
overwhelmed and overworked and there's
so much that they can do that they feel
paralyzed well i don't know what to do
first or what how do i make all of this
happen and i think that we all need to
take a few steps back
and start to get clear on our own vision
for success and then actually prioritize
making that come to life because then it
gives you such clarity and such freedom
and all of that static and the overwhelm
starts to fall away absolutely i think
all of us um when we love what we do and
when we're passionate about something we
almost have this sense of guilt about
being paid for it we shouldn't be paid
for it we can't ask for money oh i'll
just do it this one time oh i can't
charge that much i'm taking advantage of
someone else and so there's a lot of
sometimes subconscious sometimes just
deeply lodged beliefs about our own
worth and money and being paid for
something that we're really good at
that is important that we investigate
that we challenge and that we choose our
own beliefs around money because money
is this incredible thing and a lot of
women a lot of people in general but
especially women there's a lot of
conflict part of us wants more and part
of us feels guilty or greedy for wanting
it and like we're bad or somehow that
makes us i don't know less spiritual
less soulful less authentic and i think
that's total bs i think money is amazing
it is the most incredible tool that you
can use
not only to take care of yourself and
your family but more importantly that
you can funnel to
ideas and causes and real problems in
this world that take resources to help
fix and
that's really exciting to me and i think
that
the more that women are financially
empowered the more everyone wins i mean
the studies have proven this time and
time again that when women get
financially empowered they take better
care of their families better care of
their kids they actually tend to have
less kids especially in the developing
world communities become stronger
nations become stronger and really the
whole global economy is going to come
stronger so i get really fired up about
women owning what they're worth getting
very comfortable with money getting very
comfortable asking for it and also
becoming stewards of it meaning how are
they spending it on a day-to-day basis
are they feeling like you know what i
have enough right now to give to causes
i believe in i have enough right now to
invest in my own education my own
business my own future i think those are
really important issues and i think as
women we can't shy away from money we've
got to really dive into it and be
willing to swim around and investigate
all the places that we have screwed up
beliefs and that's okay all of us have
screwed up beliefs about something but
with money it's like we've got to get
this straight it's vital the more you
care about what other people think the
more they own you the more power they
have over you yeah and it's like i want
people to win that's who i am as a
person i want people to win i want them
to be well i want them to be successful
if there's anything that i could
possibly share that even a tiny nugget
of what i share helps them
become more of who they want to be then
i feel i have done my job successfully
do i have all the answers absolutely not
no way no one has all the answers but i
do believe that
what we create in our company and the
programs we put together and the things
that we share help people find their own
answers
so i don't honestly i don't care yeah i
really don't care because if someone is
going to take the time to either make
that comment or that judgment it
my perspective would be that there's
something in their own life that's not
working that puts them in that position
of feeling a sense of pain or feeling
like they have to judge someone else to
justify what's happening in their own
life i just don't think that gets any of
us anywhere i mean talking specifically
about the decision not to have kids i
remember when i did a marietv on that i
was so blown away by how many women were
like thank you for talking about this
um and i also it was friendly i was like
i was waiting for the comments i was
like i wonder how many people are gonna
say oh but you're gonna regret it or
you're gonna change your mind for me i
actually don't believe i'll regret it at
all
in my own life i've run so much of it by
my gut and by intuition and by listening
to the still small voice within
and as i said on that show that i did it
was never a decision for me i didn't
weigh my options i wasn't torn it was
clear
this meaning
who i am right now is my path
should some point happen between now and
when i die that i want to have children
in my life there are many many many
different options for me to execute
right there's adoption there's fostering
there's like a million different ways
that it could go should i change my mind
which again i'm very open to so i don't
believe in my case that i'm going to
have any regret
i believe so strongly in how my life has
unfolded and i also have tremendous
faith that it will continue to go
exactly as it's meant to and whenever my
time is up
i feel really good about the ride
changes and then really starting to see
also how much more creative and
productive i was when i scaled back a
little bit and that was a really
powerful realization because i think
often and i understand this and i think
it's it's important to contextualize
this because at different stages of our
life
and at different stages of our creative
process we need to work in different
rhythms you know often when you're
getting something off the ground it's
kind of like a rocket ship leaving the
atmosphere it takes a lot of inertia to
break free from gravity right to get
into that upper stratosphere so there's
a lot of work required in the in the
beginning but then you have to adjust as
you move on and i just needed to learn
that lesson so it was kind of
interesting when we were creating the
book and started selling it actually
into foreign markets they're like well
how are we going to define this word
everything is figure outable because it
doesn't translate into other languages
and i was like okay
it is achievable it means that something
is possible we started playing with all
these words but i think um to answer the
second question of how this phrase came
about i'm taking it back to jersey
taking it back to the 80s and taking it
back to my mom who is like this
interesting character so
she's about 5'3
she looks like june cleaver and she
curses like a truck driver
she grew up in the projects of norc new
jersey to two alcoholic parents and she
learned by necessity how to stretch a
dollar bill around the block like five
times and she promised herself that when
she got older she would find a way to a
better life
so cut to me growing up in this italian
american home there's like you know
plastic covered couches very working
class and one of my fondest memories was
me and my mom sitting at the kitchen
table and cutting out coupons so because
frugality is her number one thing in
life right she loved teaching me all the
different ways that we could save money
and she also introduced me to this idea
of proofs of purchase do you remember
those from yes so if you like save up um
the fact that you bought x amount of
boxes of cereal or whatever and you
mailed in this little piece of the box
that these brands would send you like a
cookbook or utensils like good stuff for
free
and one of my mom's most prized
possessions was this tiny little orange
radio like transistor am fm it had a
little red and white straw sticking out
of the side that was the antenna and she
got it for free from tropicana orange
juice
and my mom is the kind of person who's
always busy always doing something and
so as a kid i knew the way to find her
was to listen for the sound of that
tinny little radio coming like somewhere
from the yard or in the house
so like one day i was walking home from
school and i heard the radio off in the
distance and as i got closer it was
coming from above which was a strange
kind of orientation
and i look up and we had a two-story
house and my mom who's tiny is perched
on the top of the two-story house like
very precariously and when you're little
and you're short it's just everything is
amplified and i was like mom i was like
is everything okay like what are you
doing up there
and in her very jersey accent she's like
uh ree i'm fine you know the the roof
had a leak in it i called the roofer he
said it's going to be at least 500 bucks
i said screw that i went into the garage
there was extra asphalt i'm gonna fix it
and i was just like
okay you know that's mom
another time i came home and i heard the
radio like blaring from the back of the
house so i walked to the back of the
house and i saw the bathroom it's like
the door was cracked open
and as i pushed the door open the whole
room was filled with dust particles
there was like pipe sticking out of the
wall it looked like a bomb went off i'm
like mom what are you doing like is
everything okay and she said you know
the tiles had cracks in them and i
didn't want the bathroom to get moldy so
i'm retiling the bathroom
now tom you got to get this again is the
1980s my mom is high school educated
this was pre-internet pre-youtube
pre-google
i never knew like where i would find my
mom or what i'd find her doing but that
radio was always my clue so one day it
was in the fall and in new jersey you
know the um daylight savings had already
passed so it was dark
and it was spooky and i went home
and it was
totally silent and the house was dark
which is very odd for my family
so i walk in and i have that pit in my
stomach that you have when
you're nervous that something's wrong
and i start walking around the house
and i didn't know where my mom was
and i felt like something bad had
happened
then all of a sudden i heard these tiny
clicks and clacks and i followed this
down to the kitchen and i saw my mom
hunched over the kitchen table it was
like an operating room she had like
electrical tape and screwdrivers and in
a dozen or so little pieces her
tropicana orange was completely
dismantled i was like mom that's your
little radio what happened are you okay
is it broken and she said oh it's fine
you know the antenna was off and the
dial was
not working right so i'm fixing it
and that was the first time i thought to
ask the question that i really needed to
ask all along which was
how do you know how to do so many
different things that you've never done
before yet no one's showing you how to
do them
and she like put down her screwdriver
and she cocked her head and she looked
at me and she's like what are you
talking about it's not that big of a
deal
nothing in life is that complicated you
can do anything you set your mind to if
you roll up your sleeves you get in
there and you do it
everything
is figured out
and i was like
like just in that moment and i will tell
you this i don't know tom for sure
whether she said those three words or
that's what my childhood brain heard and
translated because you know how we do
that kind of thing
but that phrase got embedded in my soul
in such a deep level and i just said it
over and over again and then i realized
as i became an adult it's been the
single biggest driving force of my life
like from
you know continuing to get rejected on
like sports teams and cheerleading and
going again and again and like getting
out of an abusive relationship when i
was like my first love to like getting
into classes in college to
getting every part-time job i've ever
gotten every full-time job i've ever
gotten getting out of relationships into
relationships building the entire
business like i still use that phrase
every single day what if i what if i
actually follow my heart and i don't
make a living at it and all my friends
said you suck see i told you so uh
eckart actually talked about when he was
moving once his parents said really
you're gonna do this again like they've
seen him as a failure for years and then
anyways but there's that always that
voice it's like yeah yeah yeah but you
might just really fail
yeah and you know i think all of us have
that and there's
perhaps some of them like a myth that
many of us can think especially when
we're first starting out that successful
people don't have the voice anymore
that's total crap
anyone that you've ever seen anyone that
i've encountered and i've had the
opportunity to interview a lot of people
and talk to them no matter how
successful how accomplished how
well-known they still have those voices
of self-doubt they still get afraid they
still question am i going in the right
direction what's next for me and i think
the more that we can recognize that that
voice of basically you suck
is universal and we can disengage from
that and actually engage with what we
want in our lives the happier we're
gonna be and this is the other thing
none of us know
it's like everything that i've learned
and i've been able to do in my business
we never know what's gonna work we treat
every single thing as an experiment
that's the only way that you learn i
think 99 of what each of us need to do
to learn and grow not only as business
people but also as human beings if we're
going to grow it means that we've never
done that before it's going to be
uncomfortable and to be okay in that
uncertainty and that discomfort is where
the juice of life lives for me a good
life is a couple things one being fully
present in each moment because i find
that when i am fully present like you
know you and i having this great
conversation now or if i'm with josh and
we're just hanging out it does not
matter what we're doing but i feel
so
peaceful
and content
and like all is well in the world even
if there's challenges i feel a sense of
peace and that's one component of it and
i think the other component for me of
living a good life is is having good
friends and having a lot of fun i think
any time that i slip into
taking things too seriously you know
like you walk around your day and you're
like wow i have so many things to do i'm
like wait a minute this is all awesome
stuff to do and i set my life up this
way i better not take it so seriously
and have a little fun and put on some
music and dance when that kind of thread
of celebration and irreverence and not
taking things too seriously
that's what living a good life feels
like to me there's a single mantra that
has helped me my entire life bypass fear
and make really any dream i've had come
true no matter how scary it seemed no
matter how intimidating it was or how
unprepared or inexperienced i felt and
that mantra is this ready for it
start before
you're ready i'm going to say that again
start before you're ready here's the
truth erin if you wait until you feel
ready to do anything meaningful you're
going to be waiting for the rest of your
life look i have been doing this for a
long time now i've supported tens of
thousands of entrepreneurs to start and
grow their businesses across 160
industries and across 119 countries and
i've noticed some similarities among the
people who are the most successful the
happiest the people who are actually
contributing the most they all have one
thing in common and it's this
they all start before they're ready
you see i think you've misidentified the
enemy here because the enemy it's not
making mistakes it's not changing your
mind and the enemy is not your fear
the only enemy that you need to defeat
my friend is not getting started this is
what most of us just fail to realize
action is the antidote to fear action
creates progress and momentum and action
consistent action is all you ever need
to make anything happen in your life you
know it seems like you can't open a book
or read a blog post these days without
hearing somebody tell you to follow your
passion or follow your bliss or follow
your heart and yes i have said those
things too but today i want to talk
about the power of going in what can
often feel like the opposite direction i
want to talk about the power of
following your fear
i'm not talking about following your
very useful fear of big moving vehicles
and walking in front of a bus nor am i
talking about doing anything stupid or
irresponsible that could ruin you
financially what i am talking about
though is the power of following good
fear directive fear the kind of fear
that you feel when you have an idea that
just won't leave you alone an idea about
doing something that you've always
wanted to do something that's different
and bold and kind of risky where part of
you saying oh no i actually couldn't do
that but the deeper wiser part of you
wants this thing so damn bad and the
moment you imagine yourself going for it
you have worries like you know will
people laugh at me will they ignore me
maybe this isn't even really an idea
what if i do it and it sucks am i gonna
destroy my reputation am i gonna lose my
marriage and my family and wind up
living on the streets my friend steven
pressfield talks about this kind of fear
in the war of art and he says
remember our rule of thumb the more
scared we are of a work or calling the
more sure we can be that we have to do
it and he continues
the more fear we feel about a specific
enterprise the more certain we can be
that that enterprise is important to us
and the growth of our soul number three
is don't give away your power so anytime
some nasty criticism or bs comes your
way you have to say this
you cannot take me down i will not give
you that power i want you to make that
your new mantra in life you got to
realize that people can say whatever
they want but you do not have to take it
in and you don't have to let it ruin
your day your time on this earth is so
precious and it's really really
important that you protect your soul now
mistake i noticed a lot of folks making
especially in the beginning is they want
instant results they want these
blockbuster hits like a bajillion
followers on social media or millions of
dollars in sales after only a few years
or maybe even a few months worth of work
i gotta say
patience is one of the most underrated
traits in modern business do not try and
run before you can walk you gotta take
pride in starting small and scrappy and
we try and operate small and scrappy to
this day you've got to be consistent in
what you do you have to be relentless
and most important this is the thing you
need to write this down work your tail
off to make your product effing
outstanding over the long term
wherever you are on the plane jetblue
has really given thought to the details
and i love this so for example free
wi-fi and i know it sounds silly but so
many damn flights that i've taken make
me pay this extra 25 or 30 bucks just to
get worked on when i've already paid a
ton of money to fly so free wi-fi for
the entire plane i gotta say that's a
nice perk when we're all so used to
being nickel and dimed next i gotta talk
about snacks so on longer flights they
have this self-service snack situation
in the economy cabin which is so humane
and i have to tell you that in mint
which is their business class that i fly
because i mean business brett my
fantastic super cool flight attendant
brought me this refreshing lime mint
spritzer i was so impressed with that
beverage branding flying in mint class
and getting a mint drink nicely done and
last but not least brett also called me
by my first name marie instead of miss
forleo now of course he could have
called me for leo and i would have been
down for that but who doesn't want to
hear their first name and he kept
calling me by my first name throughout
the entire flight it was kind it was
friendly and it gave me the sense that
he actually cared about me
so what i want you to do is think about
all the little details in your business
where and how can you go the extra mile
for your people what can you do to make
people just feel that things are more
personable and thoughtful culturally
speaking we've mostly been taught that
the feminine is weak right that's why so
many women
man up to run a business
for me for years and years and years it
produced incredible results but you know
what at a tremendous cost
where i felt myself and my creativity
starting to just drain down where i felt
myself getting more and more stressed
less and less joyful where i found
myself feeling more and more tired and
asking the questions why because i know
my core essence so
that is one of probably the biggest
mistaken notions that we have culturally
is that the feminine is weak and it is
not
it is one of the most beautiful powerful
forces within all of us and i think and
i'll speak particularly to the women who
are watching right now
one of the most
profound things that you can do over the
course of your life especially if you
struggle with being in your feminine is
to understand that it will
unlock your most powerful
beautiful creative life that you can
imagine which includes your ability to
kick major ass in business and it
includes your ability to heal others get
a go-to mantra so this strategy involves
making up just this little phrase that
you can say to yourself in those clutch
moments either when you're about to go
into a big meeting or when you just need
to sit down and do your work mindy
kaling whom i love suggested this as a
motto
why the
not me
and she's got the book to back it up now
i have to say i've got my own version
that i pull out when i need it every
once in a while too
you're marie forleo you got this
okay
say it back you're marie
forleo you got this
yeah you do chest bump
now a little science note here when it
comes to motivational self-talk research
shows that talking to yourself in the
third person can help you actually feel
less anxiety and perform better so get
yourself a go-to mantra and some bonus
points if you use your first name when i
take a spin class a really good spin
class where i'm loving the music and i
can absolutely let go and charge into my
body i can like feel into every single
movement i can let the sweat pour off of
me i can get lost in the in the rhythm i
find that it opens up a channel in me
like nothing else sometimes it could be
taking a great walk i think i want to
push you a little bit on youtube's
channel so i really understand it yes is
it where you feel like you can hear the
little voice in your mind is it where
you're ironically you can't try and
force it to show up so often times when
i hit a roadblock in my business and i'm
just at this stalemate i'm like oh i can
go this way or this way i'm stuck let me
go work out let me go take a walk let me
take a spin class let me take a dance
class and get immersed in that so that
my subconscious and the rest of my body
has a chance to
work through it and it will produce
an answer or an insight when i'm not
looking for it it could happen at the
end of the class when i'm done in the
shower sometimes it happens on the bike
it doesn't matter but what you just have
to do is have a level of faith and trust
and you can't go in forcing it very
different i feel like what happens
through exercise and again it's when you
have that level of faith to surrender to
your body to surrender that you have
wisdom within you that you're not going
to access grinding to it
it
unfurls almost like a flower blooms when
it's ready as someone who's been
consistently creating content and
sharing content for almost two decades
now i speak from experience and i gotta
tell you being consistent with your
content creation it is so important it's
actually one of the biggest factors in
our company's success so when it comes
to coming up with things to write about
or talk about or teach about i really do
believe that i can never run out of
ideas because literally there's always
more where that came from look people we
live in an abundant ever-changing ever
expanding universe it's literally
impossible to run out of ideas i promise
you now this doesn't mean that i never
feel like i run out of ideas or that i
don't occasionally wonder if i'm tapped
out i mean believe me i have those
moments but when that happens i remember
my magical mantra that there's always
more where that came from and it changes
everything like that because there's
always another story to tell there's
always another way for me to serve
there's always someone who could use a
helping hand or a kind word or a
reminder about how freaking great they
are and from that space ideas always
always come so as i approach the gate i
knew i needed to get some work done
before hopping on that flight and i was
bracing to try and find one of those
like long vertical outlet hubs where
there's 30 people clustered around
trying to plug their stuff in so to my
very pleasant surprise i found rows and
rows and rows of these comfortable cute
little workstations all with their own
outlets and a huge sign above it that
said the juice bar i mean seriously how
many times have you said to yourself oh
crap i've ran out of juice on my phone
or my computer has zero juice i need to
go find a plug so when jetblue says
juice bar they are speaking my language
and it's a very smart plan words that
lets me know hey they get me and i gotta
tell you this every single customer
wants to feel like you as a business
owner just get them
now another quick example uh when i saw
the help desk right instead of saying
something formal like information desk
the sign said just ask so not only is
the latter more friendly and inviting
but it implies that my question is
welcome and not stupid so the bottom
line is this using your customers
language is key if you want to create
more sales and raving fans and in the
words of this tweetable your customers
language is the jet fuel to make your
business take off the most accomplished
and respected people in the world stay
humble they're curious they're
open-hearted they're lifelong learners
don't ever feel like you have to
overcompensate for imposter syndrome by
becoming an arrogant asshat know it all
not only do you not have to know it all
but you become extra trustworthy when
you say these three magic words
i
don't know
you know i consider myself a forever
student and i happily admit when i have
no idea what something is or how to do
something but you know what
everything is figure outable so not
knowing doesn't make me a fraud and it
doesn't have to make you one either i
was bartending at night waiting tables
doing assistant work like i was
basically working 24 7. you know in the
evenings and weekends it was all how can
i just make money to pay my rent and put
food on the table and in the days i was
really working my buns off trying to
create content create a newsletter get
coaching clients actually start working
with people
and um
when i got engaged really young i was
about 23 years old and the guy was a
sweetheart but i realized pretty quickly
i didn't want to marry him this was not
the person i was meant to spend the rest
of my life with but we lived in this
tiny one-room studio in the west village
and our money was already co-mingled and
so i was terrified because
i felt like i made this huge mistake
here i am trying to become a life coach
and clearly i have a lot to figure out
about life
i knew i needed to get out of this
relationship but i didn't i didn't know
how to untangle what i had created this
big mess
and so um i knew once i broke off that
engagement i needed to actually
physically leave that environment that
was the only way i was going to get to
move on and so i called my parents new
jersey and i said i hate to say this but
i have to move home i was so upset i
just felt like a total failure i felt
like a horrible person for
breaking this guy's heart and it was
just it was a mess like i just felt like
such a failure on every single level the
fact that i couldn't support myself yet
the fact that i had to go back to jersey
the fact that i felt like i you know
did a number on this guy's life
and um
it was really humbling but you know
at the end of that it made me realize
i'm more committed than ever to figure
out what it takes to make my life work
and then also to be able to share those
lessons with other people so hopefully
they didn't have to go through
the mess that i created if i could save
people learning curve that was going to
be awesome and i think i was home maybe
like two or three months something like
that emotionally i had to heal and just
kind of get myself re-situated and you
know find a new living um
a place to live in the city and get back
on my feet but it was probably one of
the best things that ever happened to me
because it got me regrounded in my own
power and made me realize that if
everything falls apart which it
sometimes does there's always a way to
get back on your feet yes indecision is
a dream killer and the opposite what do
we do about that it's probably one of
the things i live my life by most
besides the idea that everything is
figureoutable is that clarity comes from
yes
yes we'll talk about that that clarity
comes from engagement not thought so one
of the things that got me off my ass
right when i was thinking about should i
be a dancer could i be a dancer am i too
old to be a dancer oh i think i am was
just getting into that friggin dance
class that's what cracked me open to a
whole additional career that by the way
built the skill sets to what i do today
so my little kind of offshoot my weird
dancing thing got me experience in front
of the camera teaching to big groups
leading
music all the stuff that we've talked
about in this entire interview built
this incredible skill set that now fuels
the brand that i have today that's
completely unique that would have been
if i just stayed narrow and focused on
life coaching i would have been you know
that girl with like an awful pink suit
and shoulder pads terrible i don't think
that anyone should ever accept where
they're at in life doesn't matter if
you're just starting out or if you've
already hit some really big goals
because when you lose your hunger you
lose your edge and it is as simple as
that now here's the deal if we humans
don't have something meaningful and
challenging to work on we all tend to
get lost pretty darn fast and i'll tell
you something else we can go to some
pretty dark places at least i know
that's true for me so there is some
nuance to this and it's really important
that you get it so you can be ten
thousand percent grateful for what you
have right now you can uh smell the
roses so to speak and you can be super
hungry and psyched about what's coming
up next those two things are not
mutually exclusive and it's really
important that you get that fact in your
noggin every single one of us who both
dreams and creates things faces voices
of dissent both from people that we know
from people that we don't know and very
often the most deadly comes from within
and if we don't take a thoughtful
conscious approach to taking on our
unrealistic dreams they just ain't gonna
happen i want you to fend off negativity
as much as humanly possible you know we
know so much more about the brain than
we did just 20 years ago neuroscience
has taught us incredible things like
that our brains are continuously shaped
by our thoughts and our experiences and
you know this to be true i mean
negativity is one of the most toxic
forces on the planet it's toxic for your
brain for your nervous system and for
your ability to stay motivated so do me
this favor okay do not solicit or listen
to the opinions of people who are
notorious for just being debbie downers
the one mistake that i've seen people
make consistently is they almost
habitually talk to the exact person who
is the most likely to shoot them down
and make them feel like crap so don't do
that and here's another key i want you
to always always always consider the
source meaning don't put a lot of stock
into other people's opinions unless
they're actually out there consistently
taking risks and being brave and
actually making things happen i mean if
you think about it let's say i don't
know you wanted to climb mount everest
would you ever take advice from someone
who's never even attempted the summit no
of course not that would be crazy so
don't take advice from anyone unless you
really think it through and i want you
to ask has this person achieved an
unrealistic or impossible dream
are they taking meaningful risks on a
consistent basis
do you admire who they are how they live
and what they contribute if not do not
use them as a sounding board for your
idea anything that you're going through
right now
if you want to take a big scary leap and
you want to start a new career or
perhaps start a business anything that
you might consider a failure is really
just a necessary step on your journey to
success so no matter what you're facing
right now no matter what's getting you
so scared there's only one question that
you need to ask and answer to find the
courage to make that big leap and the
question is this
what's the worst thing that can happen
so not just by saying yes but what's the
worst thing that could happen if you
said no so for example a few years ago i
asked my really dear friend laura to
come speak at one of our live events now
this was a big opportunity for her but i
know it was kind of stressful and i said
you know what
this is big so take a few days think
about it because once you say yes you're
going to be locked in so first she had
to ask herself well what's the worst
thing that could happen if i said yes so
for her it was the stress it was wishing
that she never committed which she
wished she never committed but it was
also this fear that she was going to
completely freeze up on stage that she
was going to mess up horribly and
completely ruin her reputation which she
did not now on the flip side she had to
ask herself what's the worst thing that
could happen if she said no so you got
to get that laura really wanted to grow
her business and her brand and if she
said no to this opportunity she'd have
to face herself in the mirror every
single day and say nice going bonehead
you had the perfect opportunity to grow
your business and you turned it down so
now it's your turn i want you to ask
yourself what's the worst possible thing
that could happen if you said yes and
you'd fail miserably so don't just think
about this loosely i want you to get
really specific and tease out every
single scenario that could possibly go
wrong and how you deal with it if it did
what most of us discover is that no
matter what the worst case scenario is
we can actually handle it but don't
forget you gotta go on the flip side too
and ask yourself what's the worst thing
that can happen if you decide to do
nothing and keep your life exactly as it
is are your regrets gonna start to pile
up like pancakes are you gonna turn into
some miserable self-loathing sad sack i
really want you to tease this one out
and get all the scenarios on the table
and then take a look what do you got
what's the worst of the worst going for
it or not going for it i've been through
a series of traumatic events and suffer
from depression i live in iraq and my
country has been in war for decades i'm
an architect and love my job but here
everything you care about or build can
be destroyed at any moment that's if you
manage to survive so here's my cue
how can i find the courage to continue
building knowing all my hard work can be
wiped away due to circumstances i can't
control you know right now i'm in new
york and it's hard to fathom the fear
and turmoil and uncertainty that you
experience on a daily basis my heart
goes out to you and i want you to know
that we are sending you love and my hope
is that something we share today can
help you feel supported and find a sense
of strength you mentioned something
really really important when you talked
about finding the courage in the midst
of circumstances you can't control
that's the operative phrase
circumstances you can't control you're
living an amplified version of that but
you're 100 right
for all of us so much of what happens in
life is completely beyond our control
and that can leave us feeling powerless
but here's the good news
there's one thing that we have just a
smidget of control over and that's
ourselves and how we choose to direct
our thoughts and our words and our
actions
keeping this in mind when i read your
question there were two key habits that
i wanted to recommend for you both of
these can be done anywhere they don't
cost anything and they're both
scientifically proven to help improve
depression and anxiety and the impact of
trauma
habit number one
daily meditation so meditation is the
ultimate technology for creating peace
from the inside out for me it's what
helps me stay connected to the loving
and strong parts of myself and observe
my circumstances without getting swept
away by them habit number two is
movement now what's tough about this one
is that when we feel depressed or we're
under extreme mental anxiety we don't
feel motivated to do much of anything
besides maybe eating some chips or in my
case you're really craving some mac and
cheese however exercise is
scientifically proven to be especially
effective for depression you don't even
have to get fancy you don't have to go
to a gym you could run or you could work
out in your house you know there are a
ton of free videos on youtube that just
use your body weight so you don't even
need any equipment i try and play this
practice of you know if i ever feel like
in any moment life is not going the way
that i think it should be going it's
because i'm resisting what is you know
if someone didn't turn in their work on
time and i'm just like you know getting
that way or something didn't come out
right or the delivery doesn't come or
the technology breaks again we can list
anything in that slot right it's me
arguing with reality i'm making myself
miserable in that moment because i'm
choosing to argue with what is that's
always a losing proposition
so the more awareness i can bring to
that and go like is this really how you
want to live your life in this moment
marie because every single moment as you
know sets you up for the next moment and
you string these moments together and
guess what you have your life until we
get to that incredible death bed we
never know when that's coming so every
single moment is an opportunity for us
to check ourselves before we wreck
ourselves and so i just try and play the
game if i'm miserable if i'm upset if
i'm angry if i'm cranky it is my
responsibility because it's based on
what i'm thinking or believing in that
moment it's not the outside world
causing me to feel this it's what i'm
doing up here that's making me have that
reaction and if i'm the problem i am
also the solution whether you run a
business a non-profit or you just want
to be more effective in getting people
to say yes i think you're going to find
this fascinating dr robert cialdini
author of the classic book on persuasion
called influenced studied the donations
process at the american cancer society
he found that the number one game
changer in gaining more donations was
one tiny language tweak let's have a
look which one of these might make you
more likely to donate would you be
willing to help by giving a donation
or
would you be willing to help by giving a
donation every penny will help
now check this out
research showed that people who were
asked the second version were almost
twice as likely to make a donation while
only 28 percent gave money with the
first call to action 50 donated when the
call to action included that one extra
sentence
every penny will help
so let's break this down you see when
you give people a small easy action to
take it can double their chances of
saying yes by adding a simple sentence
you're creating what's known as a
minimum viable action the smallest
possible action someone could take to
create the change you want now obviously
this doesn't just work for non-profits
in fact you've probably been offered a
minimum viable action at your favorite
stores here's an example so a few weeks
ago i was at the container store because
icon married the crap out of my closet
hashtag spark joy so when i was checking
out they asked me if i was a member of
pop their perfectly organized perks
program i said i am not they said oh it
is so easy all we need is your phone
number and you will get an extra 15 off
i was like oh okay saving money like
making money here is my phone number i
want to be a popper like yesterday and
look this isn't just about business
either i mean you can use this same
strategy to double your chances of
getting yes even in your own head for
example if you've made a commitment to
exercise more which of these internal
scripts is more likely to get you moving
i need to work out today
or
i need to work out today a five-minute
dance break is better than nothing
now i don't know about you but i am way
more likely to get moving with that
second option track your successes and
your stumbles so for example every year
i do a year in review i write down each
year's successes and my stumbles and
most important what i've learned from
them all so this way i have this very
factual list of what i've accomplished
and the mistakes i made along the way
and i can see that not only did those
mistakes not ruin me but they help me
get stronger and they help me get better
which makes me less afraid of making
more of them in the future when i first
started as a business person i was 23
years old
and i was so insecure
in my mind starting a life coaching
business as a 23 year old like the
logical part of my mind was like who the
hell is going to hire a 23 year old life
coach this is the dumbest silliest
stupidest thing you've ever tried in
your life and i had been on wall street
i had worked in the magazine industry i
had done all these things and basically
hit all these different walls
and when i was trying to figure out how
to be an entrepreneur at 23 and this is
like the late 90s early 2000s this is at
the very beginning of all things digital
i felt like i didn't fit in you know i
was trying to live into this idea of who
i thought a businesswoman would be with
like big shoulder pads and you know a
corner office and tried to write an
online newsletter at that time that was
like uber professional and it was
lifeless
i wasn't getting anywhere because i
wasn't being me
and i'm just a girl from new jersey who
was brought up in a very um you know
kind of normal middle-class way no one
in my family ever went to college my
parents my mom especially you know she
curses like a sailor so i had this very
unique upbringing and i was trying to
fit myself into this idea of who i
thought i should be and it wasn't
working so it wasn't until i actually
allowed myself to just be the weird
wacky energetic kind of a little bit
crazy person that i am that things
actually started to work and so
now it's been almost 20 years of doing
this and i've seen it time and time
again where people tend to feel stuck
and stifled where they tend to feel like
their life force is just drained out of
them there's gets to be despair and
depression they just feel stuck is when
they're not expressing the fullness of
who they really are they're trying to
fit themselves into a conventional box
they're trying to live up to other
people's expectations they're trying to
be someone who they really aren't
because they're afraid that the real
them is going to get rejected i have
been this way meaning goofy silly
since i was very very little and when i
first started my coaching practice when
i was 23 i tried to be what i thought in
my mind was a business woman i had this
idea of like a power suit and some like
big old shoulder pads and i would speak
in a certain way and i remember trying
to do that and i felt horrible like i
felt so stunted it was like i had
writer's block i had speakers block i
just felt like i was in somebody else's
skin and it was so painful for me that i
was just like i can't do this but i
really want to do this thing i'm going
to let go of my idea of who i think i
should be and talk about the fact i'm
from jersey i don't use proper language
all the time i have kind of a weird
sense of humor i love zombies smurfs all
kinds of things and what would happen if
i actually just expressed that and
something funny actually did happen is
not only did i find myself to be more
creative i found myself more fulfilled
and people actually connected with me
more i didn't feel like i had to push
myself out into the world it was more
like things started to come to me and i
didn't feel like there was so much of a
separation between my work day and the
rest of my life which felt great but
jetblue has done something really
impressive they've taken the top spot in
jd power's north american airline
satisfaction study for 12 consecutive
years create an a-plus experience right
out of the gate or in this case before
the gate here's what i mean when i got
to the jetblue terminal at jfk something
was different it felt different it was
more calm and spacious and the design
had this uber intentional kind of vibe
to it there were a ton of check-in
stations like more than i'd ever seen
which meant there was no wait time for
me to check myself in there were clear
directions and clear signage and more
than enough jetblue employees around if
needed now i would love you to think
about your business so from the very
second that someone says yes to your
product or your service how can you give
them this royal treatment you know you
don't need a whole team of flight
attendants right it could be as simple
as a series of emails that welcome your
customers and really make them feel
taken care of and appreciated and
already enticed to come back again so
the fact that your energy gets embedded
into your communications we all know
that right like you've received the
email that's curt and you can just
almost feel the punch in the face that
comes through you've gotten the text
where you're like they are definitely
pissed at me
i believe and i do this a lot with email
marketing especially in our business
every time i sit down to write a new
email i want the other person who
receives this email to the best of my
ability to feel the love and the energy
and the respect and the excitement that
i have not only for the idea that i'm
about to share but for the impact it
could have on their life i want them to
feel all of me you know if i'm sitting
there writing an email and i'm like just
feeling flaccid i mean what's that copy
gonna be like it's not gonna be any good
but if i'm there and i'm like playful
and i'm excited about it so that
excitement is conveyed and when
someone's looking through their inbox
and they see something from me nine
times out of ten
because i'm consistent they know if they
click open it's going to be a good time
right there's going to be love in that
email there's going to be an energy to
that email that's different and i mean
you've probably experienced this in your
own life in simple ways when someone
makes a request of you
they care to even put an emoji because
it's not just them try it's like that
was a genuine expression of their
excitement um i'm sure if your wife asks
super something and her energy is such
that there's love embedded in it you're
a hundred times more likely to want to
say yes right
100
yes so we all feel this stuff and i
think that if you can consciously begin
to practice it then you're going to
notice the impact and the results so
envy can be inspiring and instructive if
you're envious of someone's results just
let that fuel you ahead
the fact that they did it means that it
can be done and that you can do it too
so just give them a high five and a soul
shake
second realize that envy is often a clue
that there's something latent in you
that needs to be expressed so let that
envy trigger you in a beautiful way let
it guide you to where you need to take
some more action in your own life so
next time anne that you're feeling some
envy don't feel embarrassed just
remember this tweetable
don't hide your envy ride your envy from
she has what i want to i'll have what
she's having when i first started
writing this book i floated the idea out
to my friend who has an eight-year-old
boy we're sending a brunch and he's like
what are you writing your book about and
i said i this everything is figurative
he's like i don't believe that i was
like awesome perfect that's what i said
i was like this is great tell me more
and he's like well
we humans can't grow working wings out
of our back
and i was like you're damn right i was
like but you know what we can indeed fly
and he was like oh and he was like but
you know i can't get my childhood dog
back he's dead and he died when when i
was three and i was like this kid's
intense yeah no i like it man i'm like i
bring it proof my book like totally i
said bring it to me we're like eating
our french fries together i'm dipping in
that ketchup i'm like bring it brother
and i said you are absolutely right i
said however
dog cloning is happening and they are
working on cryogenics so it may not be
figure out about right now but that does
not preclude it from being figure out at
some point
a couple hundred years ago we thought it
would be preposterous to be on the moon
walking right if you said that and yet
we did it so there are many things that
perhaps we have not put our attention on
quite yet to figure out but doesn't mean
it's not possible so
after my amazing talk with my
eight-year-old friend at brunch i
created three rules
to help all of us have a mental
container so we can do less kind of
devil's advocate and more just use this
freaking idea to help yourself and
others like could we just focus there
so rule number one all problems or
dreams are figure-out-able rule number
two
if a problem isn't figure-out-able it's
not a problem it's a fact of life i.e
death
gravity laws of nature now we can play
around in there for a minute but you
don't even have to right we could change
those rule number three you may not care
enough
to solve this particular problem or
reach that particular dream and that's
okay don't beat yourself up go find
something that you're so friggin
passionate about that you can't help
yourself but just attack it and then go
back to rule one
and those three simple rules create a
fun mental container within which you
can play and then just go and start
having fun with making your life
immeasurably better i think one of the
biggest ways that all of us can hold
ourselves back is listening to that
nasty little lie inside our head that
says i'm not ready yet i don't have
enough experience i don't have enough
credentials who am i to do x y or z and
then we just delay delay delay and
before you know it months if not years
have gone by and we haven't made any
real progress you know this was true for
me you know when i started my coaching
career one of the things i discovered
was that i just didn't want to be a
coach i've never really fit a
traditional mode and from doing all the
personal development work to train
myself to be the best coach i could be i
realized i have other passions i love
spirituality i love writing i love
digital business which was very new in
the early 2000s and i also love hip-hop
and dance yeah
and so when i was prop 25 i finally gave
myself permission to go take my first
official dance class i never had an
official class as a kid i never took
ballet or did any of that stuff i just
moon walked across my mom's floor right
and just loved hip-hop music but
starting in the dance world at 25 sounds
odd but you're kind of over the hill
yeah because most professional dancers
have been doing it since they popped out
of the womb and by the time they're 17
18 they're going on tour with the
hottest artist of the day
so
the reason i'm telling the stories it
relates to start before you're ready so
i'd finally gotten up the gumption to go
start taking classes my teachers told me
they're like you're pretty good you
should try and teach and by the way this
was in a gym environment so crunch
fitness in new york city that's where i
was taking classes because i could
afford it
and
i started becoming a substitute hip-hop
dance teacher and again i don't know
what the hell i was doing i just felt
like i was out of place but here's what
happened that's crazy one of my first
dance classes that i ever taught solo
when i got done with it this woman
walked up to me and i was still sweating
i was trying to catch my breath and she
said you're really good i was like thank
you that's amazing she said you know i
work for mtv and we're looking for a
choreographer producer i think you
should come in and meet my boss now ed
in that moment i was so green in the
dance world i didn't know what the hell
i was doing so my brain was going i'm
not ready for this yes why couldn't this
opportunity come two or three or four
years later when i know what the hell
i'm doing i'm better prepared i could
actually show up and maybe even land
this gig but here's what i realized
in my mind i was like you're already 25
which is over in the over the hill in
the dance world and
the only chance you're ever going to
have to see if this could actually be a
viable career for you is if you do this
so i remember standing outside of the
viacom building in new york city wanting
to throw up in the trash can because i
was so nervous because i didn't feel
ready but i pushed myself finally got up
to that office i knocked on the door i
just did my best in the meeting and you
know what i got the gig
and here's the thing that one experience
of being hired as a choreographer slash
producer by the way i still didn't know
what i was doing when i was working with
dancers that had 10 times more
experience than i did i was embarrassed
because i didn't know all the terms i
didn't perform at my i did the best i
could do in that moment but there were a
lot of things that i didn't know my
naivete did show however my growth and
learning curve
man it skyrocketed and that one
experience changed the entire trajectory
of my career it led to me eventually
becoming a nike elite dance athlete one
of the first in the world it led to
fitness videos choreographing
commercials for nike and reebok and all
of this stuff that would have never
happened if i didn't start before i was
ready and you had a quote about this
and you said beliefs are the hidden
scripts that run our lives and that's
one of those if you could get people to
really internalize the fact that right
now your whole life is being dictated by
the beliefs that you have yes how do you
help people unwind those beliefs how do
you help them replace them with more
powerful beliefs because
that is like a layer of the operating
system that is so wildly
underappreciated yeah that that's almost
always where i start with people yeah it
has to be i think for all of us i think
the first thing for us to go to is that
recognizing that beliefs are a choice
and every choice can be changed yes so
beliefs are a choice and every choice
can be changed do people react like
you're crazy when you say that um
you know i haven't floated that out
enough in a big enough audience to see
people like
i don't believe it i'm dying to know how
people respond let's see because i i
really think people think that beliefs
are recognition of truth
and that to try to change your beliefs
is to try to deny the truth in some way
well i mean for anyone watching whoever
believed in santa claus
right like you believed things i'm
certain that i know i have like you
believed things when you were younger
even if you weren't a child if you were
a teenager or you were a young adult
that now
experience or wisdom or something has
shown you know that's not actually the
truth
anyway my point is this we collectively
have believed things both individually
and as a society over time that we've
changed our beliefs so i think that that
is proof positive that our beliefs are a
choice and those choices can indeed be
changed you know obviously there is the
phenomenon known as confirmation bias
which is the brains um
just
it tends to reinforce what we already
believe and then ignore information
consciously or subconsciously that
doesn't match what we already believe
which is often why whenever we're having
conversations about really
delicate topics like it could be about
gun control or reproductive rights or
race and they just evolve so fast
because people hunker down in their
belief bunkers and they're unwilling to
see another point of view but i do hold
fast to the fact that all beliefs are a
choice and choices can be changed and
here's what else is cool
you know this because you're so immersed
in the world of personal development
you're someone who is so committed to
learning and growth
over the years i've read more personal
development books than you can like just
shake a tree at
and oftentimes
part of the exercise is like you have to
go hunt down all of your limiting
beliefs right so if you want to become
this powerful person and be the best
that you can be you need to find every
single limiting belief and then change
it and do all these different things
here's what i realized when writing this
book you actually don't need to do that
i have a time saving tool because
everybody needs to save some time and to
make this really effective and efficient
if you adopt the belief that everything
is figure out able and you take that on
for yourself you don't need to go
hunting down all your limiting beliefs
because that one thing is like the
master key that handles everything below
it it's almost like flipping a switch in
your consciousness where then everything
else becomes possible so let's say if
you're like oh everything is figuratible
you bump
into something in your relationship that
feels like it's problematic you're like
oh i could figure this out you don't
need to go necessarily looking for all
those limiting beliefs you may
eventually uncover them and that's cool
you can kind of clean them out but you
don't have to do all this front end work
adopt this one it's like the master key
and it'll help you achieve anything you
want for the rest of your life this is
not
like hype i'm dead serious on this
ronnie was a palliative nurse who sat by
the bedsides of the terminally ill for
years and she discovered that the number
one most common regret of folks who were
on their deathbed was this
i wish i'd had the courage to live a
life true to myself not the life others
expected of me
i gotta tell you every time i read that
or say it it gets me in the gut it's one
of those truths that i think is worth
revisiting to make sure that we're
really living the life that we want to
live not the life others expect of us so
the cue i want you to aid today actually
has three parts
part number one
what's one thing you're doing right now
not because it's true for you but
because you feel it's expected from you
part number two what's one courageous
change you'd like to make to be more
true to yourself
and part number three what's the first
action step you can take now
now don't just think about this in your
head i want you to leave a short comment
below because it will help you actually
make that change happen hey marie i'm
really struggling with imposter syndrome
no matter how many people tell me i'm
amazing and have really helped them no
matter how much progress i make in my
business and life i still feel like it's
all a fluke and i actually suck and i
should give up most people who are high
achievers feel this way but never talk
about it it's like this dirty little
secret that everyone's afraid to admit
now i will tell you right now i still
feel this way and i've been doing what
i'm doing for almost two decades my
friend brene brown says this
as a shame researcher i know that the
very best thing to do in the midst of a
shame attack is totally
counter-intuitive
practice courage and reach out
a to the men brene and amen to you z for
sharing with this question you know why
because shame always shrivels when you
share it out loud so here's what to do
to take this even further what i want
you to do is put a few people on speed
dial for when that fraud festival comes
to town and it won't go away these folks
are your new hashtag fraud squad people
who you can jump on a call with and just
say something like you know hey guys i'm
feeling like i kind of suck right now
can you remind me why i don't
now naturally you should be willing to
return the favor you want to be that
person who's always lifting others up
and reminding them of how great they are
especially when they can't see it for
themselves my question how can i go
about projecting myself as a writer
first and a teacher second what business
steps can i take to make this
transformation thank you for all you do
christina all right so christina we got
some good answers for you today there's
actually three very simple very
effective things that you can do right
now to make that transformation and make
it happen fast the first one is speak it
so words have tremendous power all you
got to do next time you find yourself at
a cocktail party just say you're a
writer first
so anytime you introduce yourself talk
about writing talk about your books talk
about everything else before you start
staying you're a teacher and that's
going to make a huge difference so um
what we like to say is just do it
just do it
just do it christina
number two number two you want to write
it so all language that goes out into
the world think about this what is your
email signature say what does your
business card say what about any social
media profiles the very first thing that
you should have is ding ding ding writer
so if you don't have writer as the first
thing listed on all of your written
paraphernalia go and make that change
right now i'll wait
do it
did you just do it
okay good
um number three and this is the most
important one of all is be it you have
to write as much as you can so if you
don't have a blog i would highly suggest
you start blogging perhaps journaling
will be more your thing but just really
be the writer that you actually are and
it becomes
pretty simple if you're doing something
habitually you're writing every day
you're putting out blog posts you're
publishing more books naturally it's
going to be the first thing that pops
out of your mouth everyone asks us from
the time that we're like in our kind of
mid-teens and when you start thinking
about you know what you're going to
major in and where you're going to go to
college and what you're going to do it's
like what do you want to do when you
grow up and it's this question that i
think is really intimidating first of
all because when we're young we might
not have that answer yet and in my case
there were a lot of things that i wanted
to do i remember having such a passion
for dance although i never took any
formal dance training until i was like
in my mid-20s i loved dance i was
passionate about fitness and health i
loved spirituality i loved reading i
loved business i actually thought at one
point i was going to be an animator for
disney so i think that part of my own
challenge and my struggle was that most
of the world was telling me that i had
to pick one thing
and all this conventional wisdom was
like if you're going to be a success you
have to narrow down pick one thing
specialize in it and be the best at that
thing and maybe in like 10 or 20 years
you're gonna be awesome
and every time i tried to follow that
conventional wisdom that told me to pick
one thing i felt like i was cutting off
a limb
even when i you know tried to just pick
life coaching and i was like i'm just
gonna be a life coach i felt horrible i
felt terrible when i decided that i was
actually gonna give dance which was
hip-hop dance and and fitness a go
thinking like okay i'm just supposed to
do this
just doing that i felt terrible thinking
i was putting life coaching on the back
burner and it wasn't until i realized
that i am a multi-passionate person i am
multifaceted there are a lot of things
that i'm not only interested in but i'm
actually good at and i need to give
myself permission to do everything
and just run away from the conventional
wisdom that's actually when i started
feeling good about myself and that's
when i actually started getting traction
in the world and when i say traction i
mean started getting better projects
started getting paid more started
actually building skills that now are
crucial for my business and vision is
great some people have amazing huge big
grand visions and they love it and they
step into it and they rise up to that
occasion and that's awesome like if
that's you and that's how you're built
and that's what works for you
rock on for many people when they have
an enormous vision it paralyzes them
they have no idea how to accomplish it i
see people crying workshops all the time
it's so big i don't know how to do it i
want to change the world i'm like don't
worry about changing the world change
one person's life if we can focus there
stay there for a little bit we're gonna
get to that thing maybe otherwise it's
all good because you're still doing the
work that you were born to do one of the
things about my team in particular is we
do share a lot of dna so everyone does
have very high standards they want to be
the best they want to crush it they want
to come out with new things they want to
be innovative they want to always be at
that next level so i can only play with
people like that because they're the
only people that get my kind of little
weirdness and craziness so that's number
one number two is we're also realists
and we've been in this game long enough
to realize you're not going to hit a
home run every single time
i always like to call it the snl effect
like i love snl i think it's a great
show i've always watched it you know but
you don't get to dick in a box unless
you actually do all of these other skits
i mean it was one of the funniest in my
opinion i know people are like but it
was one of the funniest skits back in
the day it was hilarious and i remember
watching that thing
so many times and going like this is
genius remember justin timberlake and it
was just like this whole thing again in
today's culture in 2019 culture that
would get ripped apart i'm talking about
in that particular moment in time i
thought it was funny
you don't get to some of their most
hilarious skits unless you produce a lot
of work so coming back to your point in
terms of high standards you can have
really high standards for things
but you have to allow yourself to do a
lot of volume and make mistakes so an
example was in the fall we went out and
did some things on the road that it was
a new thing and we're not using any of
the footage because it wasn't very good
i'm not crying in my cereal over that
that's like part of the game so i think
it's very possible to have high
standards which is different than
perfectionism
and allow yourself the grace and the
space to play and experiment and fall on
your face or not use stuff rather than
feeling like you have to strain that big
beautiful brain of yours to come up with
ideas you can literally snatch them from
all around you because everyday life
contains endless material
things that you overhear something you
notice out the window maybe it's a lyric
from a song or a scene from something on
tv an interaction that you had in the
line at starbucks literally content is
everywhere it's like air but unlike air
you can snatch it so here's an example
one day i was here in new york city and
i overheard this woman on her cell phone
as she walked past me she was super
upset she was frustrated and she said
i'm just not great with financial stuff
i just can't handle it and yes she was
british so immediately i whipped out my
cell phone and i shot this video right
here and i talked about why it's so
important that people stop telling
themselves these negative stories about
money and i talked about how important
it is especially for women to take
charge of their finances then a couple
hours later i slapped that thing up on
facebook and boom content snatched and
hatched
i studied finance in college and i
remember knowing i have so much energy
and i didn't see myself sitting behind a
desk doing corporate finance and i
thought the only place that i could
possibly thrive was on the floor of the
new york stock exchange because there's
actually no physical seats you run
around all day long it's kind of crazy
and intense and it sounded pretty
awesome to me
and when i got there i felt so grateful
to actually have a job and have a good
job and it was so exciting feeling like
you're in the center of the financial
universe and when i looked at all the
people around me you know they were
making tons of money like ridiculous
amounts of money more than i could even
comprehend but as time went on i started
to realize that they weren't happy and i
wasn't happy it was like everyone i
worked with they only looked forward to
these two weeks a year that they had
vacation and i was like this is not my
life this is not what i'm supposed to do
and this little voice inside me kept
saying this is not where you're meant to
be you're meant to do something bigger
you're meant to do something greater but
the whole problem was that little voice
didn't tell me what i was supposed to be
doing it just was saying this isn't it
so eventually it got so loud and for me
my intuition speaks very viscerally like
i hear things inside and it starts to
get so uncomfortably physically that i
have to make a move and i finally um
found myself one day so miserable i felt
like i was gonna cry and i had to
actually leave the floor and i walked
out and right near wall street there's
trinity church and um i was raised
catholic and so i saw the church and i
was like i have to go to the church and
i sat on the steps and i pulled out my
cell phone i called my parents i was
crying my eyes out i felt like such a
loser because
i grew up in a very middle class family
my parents busted their buns to put me
through school and here i was having
this
safe and secure job
for all intents and purposes an amazing
job and i wanted to quit and i didn't
know what i wanted to do and so i just
told them i don't want to
you know be a failure but i can't do
this anymore my dad said something so
powerful to me i will never forget it
he said
don't worry about the money he's like
you have to figure out what you love if
you figure out something that you love
to do everything else is going to take
care of itself so if you've got to quit
quit
and everything will work out and i
remember i walked back into the floor
and i like had to you know wipe my face
and um that was the beginning of the end
i think within like two weeks i gave my
notice and i had to leave if you've got
all your attention on yourself thinking
well what's going to generate a whole
bunch of likes or what's going to get
people talking about me
or what's going to make me more famous
or me more relevant or me more popular
you are thinking about content creation
in the wrong damn way because whether
you realize it or not you're
prioritizing self-importance over being
of service you're thinking about what
you can get versus what you can give
which is always a losing proposition
this is especially true on social when
you're locked into what i call the me me
me mind that's a guaranteed way to make
sure that you feel desperate anxious and
unworthy and i don't know anybody who
can come up with great content ideas
when they're feeling desperate anxious
or unworthy do you of course not i was
always into a lot of different things i
had a ton of energy i remember i would
make up dances with my friends and like
choreograph stuff in the living room and
then i would go and i remember actually
having encyclopedia britannica and like
copying it down and like rewriting the
content making new pictures and creating
things
um so as a little girl i was
always wanting to learn new things do
new things and create stuff um
you know i was a cheerleader so i was
and by the way i wasn't a cheerleader
for a while i got rejected so many times
i tried out i can't even tell you i
would practice in my living room i'd put
the video camera up to try and like
figure out why my arm wasn't straight
enough
but um i always just wanted to express
myself in all these different ways and
when you know my parents kept these
great books of when i was little where
you kind of record what your kids want
and what they're into and all those
things and i remember in the section
where it says well what do you want to
be when you grow up it was always five
to seven things it was never just one
thing and they were all completely
different it was like from dancer to
teacher to model to actress to writer
like all these different kind of
professions that sounded fascinating to
me um so that was me when i was little i
was all over the place i'm always
focused on the long game i think
these days a lot of people want insta
results they want to be instagram famous
they want to have like a billion dollar
business overnight and if you're just
starting out you've never run a business
you've never created content you've
never sold marketed built a team done
any of these things before to expect
instant results it's immature it's
unrealistic you're never gonna get there
and some of the people i admire most in
the world no matter what their craft is
dude they're in it for the long game
they're not sitting around going like
you know why can't i get higher
conversions by tomorrow it's like that's
not how this works man and if you're
looking for that type of
result it's just like i'm not interested
in hanging with those kind of people i
think we get better over time i think
you have to really be patient i think
people have to understand especially
when it comes to any so-called like
glamorous type career or people
maybe things that people perceive are
glamorous whether it's something like
what you and i do an athlete an
entertainer do you know what ninety
percent of the work is
grunt work
that's what it is it's unglamorous
sometimes people like i wanna see what
you do more i'm like you wanna see what
i do more i'm sitting with a messy bun
in my sweatpants sometimes not showering
for three goddamn days because i'm
hammering out that's what i do i love it
but if you're not willing to put in that
kind of work you're not gonna get the
outcomes on the other side i work so
hard to get my business off the ground
and i was often working seven days a
week you know not just coaching like
that was a portion of what i did but to
keep a roof over my head it was
bartending it was waiting tables it was
like being a personal assistant cleaning
people's toilets whatever i needed to do
in order to pay my rent you know put
food on the table and actually continue
to grow the business so i basically
developed a habit of working non-stop
and before marietv oh yeah like getting
the business off the ground like i
worked sidekicks fitness coach she did
like dance instructions i was a nike
elite dance athlete i you know taught
anywhere from like three to seven
classes a week at crunch fitness some of
them were choreographed some of them
were basic fitness i had the coaching
clients i was doing the content and i
was bartending a waiting table so i had
developed this
habit of non-stop work because that was
what was necessary at that time in new
york yes
what's the biggest lesson you've learned
in the last decade for you
that things first of all keep getting
better
i think in our society especially as for
at least to um you know as you get older
at least in my family there was a lot of
kind of cultural expectations like oh
over this age it kind of starts going
down or you know what i mean you're kind
of you peak when you're young and that's
when all the good stuff happens and for
me i feel like it keeps getting better
and i love
that
the best years are still ahead of me and
that all the stuff that i've been
through there's like all of these
exciting new possibilities so that's one
of the biggest lessons and i think the
other one is that i don't have to stress
as hard like as a human being i have a
really strong work ethic but i also tend
to put a lot of pressure on myself and
the other lesson i've learned is that i
don't need to do that that the work
actually gets done more joyfully and
more creatively if i don't add on that
additional layer of pressure and stress
i'd love to hear about kind of being a
media maker and kind of the thought you
put into kind of the message you want to
show people
yeah that's actually been a really um
interesting evolution because i am
naturally a super goofy person i'm
naturally sometimes an inappropriate
person there's things that pop out of my
mouth as being a person from jersey that
other people would say you cannot say
that on stage you should not be talking
about that as a professional woman i'm
like but that's real and when i have
meetings with other people that aren't
on camera that there's no recording
device around that's actually how they
talk too so why are we separating
ourselves to be like this very
one type of person when we feel like
we're out in public and then in private
we act a completely different way i just
think that's so hypocritical and so for
me i feel like also the the way that i
best express myself is when i'm not
trying to be anything other than who i
actually am and how i would talk to my
friends you know it's been interesting
too with marietv it's like
i'm a woman who enjoys clothes
and i'm a woman who enjoys
like sometimes it's sassy and sexy
clothing and sometimes it's not
sometimes it's very um you know there's
boxy things that i want to wear and
sometimes it's really casual and
sometimes it's a little bit more elegant
but those are all sides of me and so
it's been interesting because sometimes
i'll put something on i'm like
there's a little too much skin am i
sending the wrong message to young women
but then i also have another voice in my
head that says but you know what i
actually like this dress and it makes me
feel good and i feel confident so i
think it's it's something that i don't
feel like i have perfectly figured out
but it's certainly a conversation that
is very relevant it's very present in my
mind it's very present for our team
because what we want to do is create
media that first of all the content is
really impactful and second of all that
we're being true to who we are and for
me being true to who i am and third of
all
giving young women a different and
diverse look at what it means to be
successful what it means to be yourself
and that you can show different sides of
you and be taken seriously
i was writing the manuscript
uh like
writing okay let's be real i was like
bleeding like oh i can't write this like
you know just trying to pound out on my
keyboard i am not an easy like
everything flows kind of writer it's
very torturesome for me
and i was trying really hard to write
the manuscript i saw my friend toby we
said hi he's like marie how's the
business what's going on what's
happening in your life and i said
everything is great and i'm working on
this manuscript and he's like
why are you doing a book he's like
that's so much work and that's such a
huge commitment and everything else
seems to be going great it's not like
you need to write a book
and i said toby
if i got hit by a bus tomorrow which
could happen i don't want it to happen i
hope i'm around for a very long time but
if i got hit by a bus tomorrow this is
the one idea that i would want to leave
behind that's it
everything else i've done that's awesome
it's beautiful i'm proud of it
but if i can communicate this idea
effectively and give people the gift
that i was able to receive from my mom
growing up
like i could
go on to the next adventure feeling very
satisfied there are many
different ways i think that we can deal
with the haters i'll tell a quick story
because i
was over a decade ago and i had just
created b-school it was the first time
launching something of that scale i had
done other group coaching programs and i
had already been successful in my
business and taking care of myself and i
remember going to this business
conference where i was really excited
because i was clear my audience was like
tiny it was
devoted but small and i wanted so badly
to share this idea i said i know i need
promotional partners so i went to this
business conference and i had like
you know like cheesy ass binders like
big plastic binders filled with things
and like my lanyard and i was like going
up to the main session and i was on the
escalator in this hotel and there was a
gentleman on the escalator with me who
was also part of that conference and as
you do they're like doing small talk
like oh who are you what do you do and
so he asked me um you know what's your
company what are you here for what are
you doing
and i was so freaking excited tom and i
told him all about this new thing
b-school and how it's going to help
people build and grow their businesses
with integrity and it had you know it
was all aligned with your heart and your
value system and it actually works and
there's like style and humor and all
this stuff
he literally laughed in my face
and he was like
are you for real wow is this a real
business come on you gotta have a rich
boyfriend or husband bankrolling you
there's no way this is a real business
wow and like you gotta get i'm from
jersey and it's very hard one to like
get me to be speechless two i was like
can i just grab him by the freaking
collar and throw him off this damn
escalator like i was like what is this
1808 not 2008 like how do chauvinistic
[ __ ] like this actually still exist
like i was completely baffled
anyway
we got up to the top level of that
escalator and he went his way and i just
kind of recomposed myself but i gotta
tell you i really thank him for not
believing in me
i call it you fuel because in that
moment i had such a big fu in me that it
fired me up to spend the rest of my time
at that conference doing everything i
possibly could
to make my program a success do you know
what i mean and so i hustled even harder
i
was even more charming and trying to be
persuasive as i possibly could be
because i was so motivated to prove that
[ __ ] wrong and i completely get as a
coach like having that kind of fu fuel
as a long-term motivation is not healthy
but i also think in the moment we have
to work with what we have like to just
alchemize the anger the frustration
someone putting you down and to use it
as a positive and productive
vehicle to help you move ahead because
you made it this far in a video i want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing louise hay motivation
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i'm not
talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear
i'm talking about just really respecting
and appreciating this incredible